and Canada should never ever be in a
position like that now I the talking
points I've been hearing over the last
couple of days from you and Minister
Wilkinson or that well now we're you
know we're calling Putin's Bluff
but that wasn't what you said in early
July when you made the decision there
was no talk about calling a bluff or
playing a game with Mr Putin know what
you said
was that um returning the turbine was
integral for Germany's economy and its
citizens
as the country is currently heavily
dependent on Russian energy that was
what you said you didn't tell the
Canadian people you did to call anyone's
Bluff until I think yesterday when I
read your comments in the globe so
that's just not fair to say at all that
this is about calling Mr Putin's Bluff
and the fact that stretches credulity in
my mind to say that your conversations
with the Germans back in early July or
June whenever you were meeting was about
calling Mr Putin's Bluff it was about
domestic Supply encouraging domestic
Supply now the Ukrainian Canadian
Congress has said that irrational also
makes no sense and we'll hear from them
later uh it's been known for years that
Mr Putin uses energy as a foreign policy
tool to punish enemies and that it was
entirely predictable
uh the Russia would continue to use
energy as a weapon and after Canada
acquiesce to Russian blackmail
essentially the reality is this was a
terrible decision it puts Canada in a
terrible spot it doesn't help Germany uh
and and makes Canada to look weak in the
eyes of the Russians isn't that right
minister
um so Marty of course uh I hear uh your
preoccupation and I I hear the
preoccupation of the UCT at the same
time the reality is that for too long
Europe has been depending on cheap
Russian gas as mentioned by Minister
Wilkinson by Jonathan in his remarks and
that was also reiterated yesterday when
I was with my colleague the Minister of
Foreign Affairs from Germany and Elena
berbuk
um from from for too long Germany has
been relying on that gas Europe not only
Germany many other countries including
the Czech Republic and others have been
relying on that gas but now the reality
is that they are moving from relying on
cheap Russian gas to uh also finding new
Solutions and that's why they've been in
active conversations with our government
but we'll just I will just continue to
answer your question
yeah I know Marty but my goal is really
to answer your question now at the same
time this was not an easy decision to
make
and for many weeks Jonathan and I were
actively in conversation with our German
counterparts which reached out to us
from the beginning and also with
ukrainians to try to facilitate the
conversation not only between the three
of us but mainly between Germany and
between Ukraine because this is also
something that is between the both
countries now to make sure that we would
keep the alliance together that we all
agree that we need to continue to be
strongly United behind Putin we need to
make sure that they would need I mean
any form of pretext any form of Alibi
and that's why the expression of calling
Putin's Bluff is the one that we're
using let me ask you that is why what's
the greatest respect Minister why didn't
you say you were calling as Bluff in
early July
well at the time the decision was still
being discussed
because that wasn't the rationale then
was it but no no no that was always the
rationale because of course Marty
if it was the reason now why did you say
that in early July
to be United until that time we were
still in discussion with ukrainians the
last conversation I had about the
turbine with my colleague my Ukrainian
colleague was actually when I was at the
G20 I think it was in Bali I it was two
o'clock in the morning and I had a
discussion with Minister culeba and the
Ministry of Foreign Affairs
um from Germany I do have them at the
time and I I I think but I'm giving you
the fact that I get to ask more than one
question so so much for just giving you
the fact I appreciate it for you to be
able to understand yeah I understand
um when you were doing your due
diligence on this decision did you um
did
um the German government tell value that
they needed the return of these turbines
to increase gas supply
that was never part of the discussion to
the contrary
they never asked you they never told you
they needed the turbine so the gas
supply could be increased
in terms of increasing gas supply that
was never the case maybe Jonathan wants
to add something to that
no but if I want to ask a conversation
I'll ask him a question okay now let me
ask you but Marty do you want the answer
well Marty I mean that question actually
was the subject of conversations between
myself and the Germans as you would
expect in terms of energy ministers so
I'm happy to answer your question
um we we certainly discussed the issues
around gas supply as you know there was
concern about the reductions within the
pipeline and the and the Russian
statement that this was as a result of
the turbine and so certainly we talked
about how returning the turbine
potentially could address that issue if
in fact the Russians were telling the
truth although most of us were of the
view that they were not and therefore it
was really very much about calling the
bluff of the of the of the European of
the Russians and and as I as as my
colleague has said that that statement
and that approach was supported not just
by Germany but by the European Union and
by the United States at the time you
made this decision was there any
discussion of calling Mr Foods Bluff at
the time absolutely and and certainly I
discussed that with Minister habek
German energy Ministry was absolutely
part of the conversation late June and
early July absolutely it was okay
I spoke about that with secretary
blinken yeah
and he was also supportive because we
all agreed that that we needed to be
United against Putin so why didn't you
say that when you made it
Mr chair I think we have used up all of
our time Mr Bergeron
we thank you Miss bandayan I was trying
to communicate with our clerk just to
understand how much time we had uh for
Mr morantz Mr Clerk
we are at six minutes and 15 seconds
thank you Mr Morant I am handing the
chair back to you
and uh I accept the chair and uh it's an
interesting meeting passing the chair
around but uh here we go
um now I Mr clerk because we're doing
this virtually you're gonna have to tell
me who is the uh up next
uh let me see
it will be missing Ben Diane for the
Liberal Party okay Miss Miss Bandai of
the floor for six minutes thank you Mr
chair always nice uh to see you in that
chair Mr Marantz
um thank you it has now been uh six
months uh nearly since uh the beginning
of of the brutal uh War begun by Russia
against Ukraine and I want to begin uh
obviously by iterate reiterating
um the unwavering support of our
government for the Ukrainian people in
their fight for freedom and how
important the work of this committee is
not only in our study on Ukraine but of
course the present study as well and I'd
like to thank the ministers for
appearing before the committee certainly
ministers you would agree um that Canada
has played a leadership role in rallying
our allies around the world in in order
to put in place one of the most robust
sanctions of regimes ever against Russia
and I believe we need to continue to
strengthen those sanctions as we did
just this week on Tuesday and and
certainly continue to to act in this
leadership role
um but that of course makes it all
the more difficult to be
um discussing the decision today a
decision
um of a few weeks ago to send the
Siemens turbine from Montreal to Germany
at Germany's request fundamentally our
sanctions are only as strong as our
unity and solidarity amongst allies and
I I guess my question then to you
ministers is really what were you
hearing at the time because
reports that I have read are to the
effect that Germany and indeed the
German foreign minister said at the time
while we were making this difficult
decision that if Germany did not get the
turbine then they wouldn't have any gas
and quote we won't be able to support
Ukraine at all because we will be caught
with popular uprisings end quote so I
think this makes clear certainly to me
and to Canadians that are listening how
consequential this decision really was
in order to maintain the solidarity of
the Allies
against Russia and maintain a strong
sanctions regime I understand Minister
Wilkinson that you were in regular talks
with the foreign minister of Germany on
this issue at that time and so I'll
begin by directing my question to you
the information that you were getting
from Germany at the time was it
concerning to the point that it may have
risked the solidarity and the unity of
um of the Allied group that we had
worked so hard to help pull together
well the short answer is yes
um I cannot over emphasize the depth of
the concern on the part of the Germans
but also on the part of the European
Union with respect to the potential
implications associated with them uh
effectively not being able to access
natural gas
um and uh and you know the the German
energy Minister Minister habeck who is
also the vice chancellor of Germany
reiterated that to me on many occasions
I spoke to him almost every day for
several weeks but I would say it's no it
wasn't just limited to the Germans it
was also the the energy commissioner of
the European Union who underlined this
very strongly Miss Simpson um in in the
discussions that we had and I will also
tell you that in the conversations we
had with the United States they
reflected and they shared the concerns
around the divisions that could end up
undermining support for Ukraine which is
in nobody's interest
I also have a question for you Minister
Jolie I don't know if you want to follow
up but allow me to ask you the question
because the Global Mail published very
worrying reports this week
um that have to do with
the treatment reserved for our Personnel
at the embassy uh Canadian and others
and the security situation they find
themselves in so
I want to under or ask how we support
our Personnel in Kiev
and you can you can follow up on the
question I asked previously as well if
you want just to take up the issue
you've just raised
as my colleague Jonathan Wilkinson was
talking to the German minister of energy
habeck I was in contact with the
Minister of Foreign Affairs from Germany
and the
representatives for foreign relations
foreign affairs from the EU and
Secretary of State of the us so we were
unanimous in the approach to be adopted
um that we did not want to give any
pretext or justification to President
Putin in this topic so this idea of
using energy to Blackmail Europe
was an approach of preventing this this
black male if you want was an approach
we wanted to develop jointly with our
allies to answer your question uh it is
clear that when we think about locally
hired staff or Canadian diplomats
working abroad
for me as Minister of Foreign Affairs I
have a moral obligation to ensure their
security
so I would like to definitely reiterate
before this committee and thank you for
asking the question
because the government of Canada
never had any information on any sort of
list that was putting our diplomatic
Canadian diplomats in danger and are
locally hired staff in Kiev I think it
is very very important to
put this on the record to be clear on
the subject
because it is very clear that this is a
decision this is rather information that
concerns the lives
of people with whom we work and this is
uh a decision that I'm taking very very
seriously
thank you question and that is for the
deputy Minister
um who I believe is is on the line the
deputy minister to Global Affairs a
deputy are you aware of any information
suggesting that staff at our Embassy in
Kiev were targeted by Russian kill lists
as reported by The Globe and Mail
uh thank you thank you thank you madam
and Diane that is your time Mr Bergeron
you have the floor
Mr chair can the witness be allowed to
answer the question with a yes or no
uh we have a very short time with the
minister so I'm going to keep it uh very
tight uh yes or no answer you can submit
your question writing to the clerk if
you like
uh
Mr chair maybe I we can allow metamorgan
to respond with a yes or no
aware of any list specifically targeting
locally engaged staff at our Embassy and
Keith
um
thank you Mr chair first of all I'd like
to
underline as I did
in a previous session of this committee
which led to this session today that I'm
convinced that the decision made by the
government of Canada
was not an easy decision to make and
I think it would be way too easy to
Simply blame the government of Canada
for this decision that was made
this decision could appear and that is
the case for Block liberal quebecois to
have been a shame and potentially
dangerous
but I imagine that the government of
Canada and this is what the ministers
have explained to us the government of
Canada was in a position that was
extremely difficult
and the decision
uh was very very difficult to make I
don't dispute the fact I would like to
thank the ministers
for being with us and for responding to
our questions
it is extremely unfortunate that Canada
found itself in this type of a situation
and being aware of the fact that
the only person to breed to be really
blamed for the situation is Vladimir
Putin sitting in the Kremlin
and everyone acknowledges that it would
have been preferable that we wouldn't
have found ourselves in a similar
situation but having said that that was
the situation in which we found
ourselves and I think it is important
right at the outset Mr chair that to to
send the message that this exercise in
which we're engaged today
will definitely be followed closely by
Russia I don't want to be uh I don't
want to appear like a paranoid person
but I think that will be the case and we
can share of course our disagreements
within political parties here at the
House of Commons or between allies
um but I think it is very important and
when we're facing Russia the most
important thing rather is Unity so
one of The Wishes we voiced was that
when the government of Canada made the
announcement for this authorization
of
exporting the turbine towards Europe was
that at that point in time that Canada
and Germany would step up the sanctions
against Russia and support provided to
Ukraine
um is this something that is seriously
considered by the Canadian side thank
you dear colleague thank you Stefan for
your question
it is clear that our objective is once
again to strengthen the sanctions regime
you've seen that this week we announced
new sanctions more than 40 sanctions
additional sanctions towards
individuals who were behind the
atrocious crimes perpetrated in Butcher
and we are ready to announce additional
sanctions as well so as is the case
since the beginning of the invasion we
will continue every week or every two
weeks to announce new sanctions we're at
1 600 sanctions at the moment and I'm
having this conversation I had a similar
conversation with Heather this morning
with Michael Chung
also so we're we're constantly looking
for ways of strengthening the sanctions
uh regime because it is a critical
subject and we have to show tremendous
amount of unity in this question because
Russia does indeed follow very closely
everything touching Ukraine and
especially developments that are taking
place in Canada and I would also hope
Madam Minister that the
the implementation of this sanctions
regime will be done in such a way that
we these won't be examples of wishful
thinking but rather more concrete
applicable
sanctions so the decision was made this
decision is temporary and revocable
uh
first question then we were led to
believe that temporary meant a period of
two years and that it concerned up to
six turbines is this
can you confirm this information yes I
can confirm this information
and if members of the committee are
interested in having a copy of the
authorization I'd be more than happy to
make that available to you having said
that after many conversations with the
German governments with our other
European and American Allies
and together with Jonathan and myself we
made the decision to make sure that
these six turbines so the entire
contract will be concerned because we
did not want President Putin to play
with one or two or three turbines
so by taking that step step
so these these six turbines we wanted to
send them back not to Russia but to
Germany so in that case President Putin
wouldn't be able to use these as
justification or as a pretext
uh many Minister we would be happy to
have a copy of the authorization sent to
the clerk of the committee please final
question unless I have more time this
authorization is revocable
so what would be the conditions that
would lead the government of Canada to
decide to revoke this authorization
of course we always make these decisions
jointly with our allies what I can tell
you now is that
the tradition the commercial relations
between Siemens and gas prom is is a
relation in which the government of
Canada is not involved so
stand for her six minutes Mrs will first
send you over the floor thank you Mr
Bergeron thank you Mr chair and thank
you very much to to both of the
ministers for being with us today and
and for having answered some of my
questions previous to this meeting as
well I appreciate your time and I and I
like my colleague From the Block
appreciate that this would have been a
very difficult decision for you to make
um I wanted to start today to to ask
some questions about about the turbines
and and the sanctions regime writ large
because you know as as much as we've
heard from from Minister Joe Lee that we
have 1600 sanctions in place I think
Canadians are mostly concerned about
whether our sanctions are working
because the sanctions don't matter it
doesn't matter how many there are it
doesn't matter who's being sanctioned if
if Canada can choose to waive those
sanctions or if those sanctions aren't
being enforced or you know if the
sanctioned regime isn't working then it
doesn't really matter how many sanctions
we have what we're sanctioning if we're
not following through on that and I
think you know as as all of us here we
want to do everything we can for the
Ukrainian people I think that this has
been one of those those moments in time
where I have seen members from all
parties work so hard to make sure that
that the ukrainians understand that
Canada wants to support them the
Canadian parliamentarians want to
support them
um so so to start
um I'm just going to ask you Minister
Julie you know the thing that keeps
popping into my mind is this whole
decision was based on the idea that
there is any trust any belief that Putin
would in fact continue to provide gas to
Germany you know we have seen him
weaponize energy already we have seen
him weaponize food there are 40 million
people around the world that are at risk
of starvation because of Putin you know
he lies we know Putin lies we know he is
not going to act in good faith we know
he's not going to follow the rules why
call the bluff as you say when when
realistically he he's already told us
he's already told the world what he
intends we already knew the bluff was
there so so now what we've done is we
we've weakened our sanction regime we've
weakened Canada's standing with Ukraine
and yet we haven't actually helped get
gas to Germany so so my question to you
is very very very straightforward will
you cancel the waiver for the other
turbines immediately
so the goal of course is to work
together amongst allies to make sure
that we are united and strong
and
when taking decisions because really
Canada in this context is in between
Germany and Ukraine and so our goal was
really to make sure that we could all be
United so people understand that
ministers
just because you know how little time I
know I know I don't know so our goal is
not to like you said because Putin is
lying that we don't trust them we don't
want to
give him any form of justification and
pretext and that's why we're calling his
bluff and that's why also we want to
make sure that he doesn't use the number
of turbines as an issue it's one permit
one time and it is done now you will not
be waving it then of course our goal is
to make sure that should Siemens and
gasprom taken a different commercial
decision well of course the government
of Canada will take stock of that
decision
so at this point you're leaving it in
the hands of the Russian Federation and
Siemens to make a decision on whether or
not the Canadian sanctions will be will
be waived
um
why the turbine is still in Germany why
is it still there
well that's up to the Germans to answer
and the Russians to answer but our goal
was to what was to send the information
the the the turbine to Germany and also
I would say while this is obviously
something that has attracted a lot of
attention we are actively working
Jonathan and I with uh Germans and
Europeans to find solutions for Germany
as they're decreasing their Reliance on
uh cheap uh artificial gas now very
important very important that we do that
and I and I appreciate that
um before I run out of six percent I
think they're now at 26 and they need to
decrease them even more and I'm going to
talk to the minister or the Ambassador
about that but yeah um in the meantime I
will have some questions about the
sanctions themselves so you know as I
mentioned Canadians want to know if the
measures your government has taken are
having the desired effect you know I've
put questions on the order paper I've
asked questions in the House of Commons
um and I can't get responses in fact the
response I got back from your government
was appalling Global first and it
basically said that because the data was
not complete or may not be complete the
department refused to share even a
partial list so so I had to actually in
fact raise a point of privilege in the
House of Commons because my job as a
parliamentarian to hold you to account
was was impossible to to do
um what I need to know is you know how
many assets has Canada seized to date
um when will we be able to get that
information how do we know how the
sanctions are being determined you know
who is who is working on this and where
is this information and how how can we
get it
so Heather and I think your questions
are extremely valid because obviously
it's important not only to have a
sanctions regime but also to be able to
implement it so the information we have
is the information that was made public
through the RCMP which is not under
Global Affairs Canada but that is
implementing these the sanctions at this
point the latest information in June was
that around 120 million uh uh
worth of assets had been frozen and that
there was 289 million dollars in
transaction that have been blocked of
the result of of uh of the sanctions now
Canada
um of the of the um
were they were these seized under
section 4-1-b of the special economics
measures act or were all the sanctions
in response issued under the broader
four-point thank you uh Ms McPherson but
Marty if I can just finalize on that
Heather you know I don't have that
specific and information but we can
provide that to you okay thank you thank
you Minister beginning uh round two uh
we have Mr bazan for five minutes Mr
present you before
thank you Mr chair and I want to thank
uh ministers Julian Wilkinson for
joining us today I have to say that I am
very disappointed and embarrassed uh
that Canada's been out played no
maneuvered by Vladimir Putin on the
Russian Federation they keep talking
about Colleen Putin's Bluff but uh we've
got to remember Putin's always playing
chess and seems like the government of
Canada is playing checkers uh I believe
that by returning the turbines here that
this is the thin edge of the wedge that
will undermine our entire sanctions
regime because what's going to happen
next time you know Russia is pushing for
something and we have to call his bluff
so I want to ask uh Minister Jolie if
she looked at any analysis and impacts
this decision will have on Ukraine
so thank you James of course we take
into account uh Ukraine's reality when
taking any decision that's why Minister
Wilkinson and I had contact with our
counterparts I even spoke to dimitro
culiba yesterday he didn't raise the
issue of the turbine when we discussed
the question was much more Ukrainian
grains getting out of Odessa making sure
that there's more financial support to
Ukraine directly as Ukraine is uh
dealing with uh a currency that is
obviously affected uh by by the war and
so making sure that we provide us but
also other allies more financial support
and at the same time we talked also
about military support and you saw what
the Minister of Defense announced today
about the resumption of the of operation
unifier and I welcome the resumption of
operation unifier I think it's necessary
but I'll say this thank you did you do
you realize that um this year uh so far
Russia has only been able to generate
about 95 billion dollars from European
gas sales uh last year uh it was over
524 billion dollars in sales to Europe
uh
do you realize uh about a minister that
gas problem is over 50 controlled by the
Russian government and gas problem you
know a couple years ago had net revenues
of over 123 billion dollars American so
that means 62 billion dollars is going
back to Russia because they own 50 of
the company or over 50 and we know that
the Russian federation's budget is over
45 made from oil and gas Revenue
so
did you consider that the dollars a gas
problem is going to get it's going to go
back to the Chrome I'm going to help
fuel Putin's War Machine like buying
more AK-74 military rifles I'm going to
go for about 800 bucks a piece or buy
more cruise missiles and and all the
other uh artillery that's been fired
into to Kiev and around Ukraine that has
already been estimated to cost over 80
million dollars and if we're going to
give them 62 billion dollars more how
much more damage is that going to and
entail upon Ukraine and how many our
lives are going to be lost so I want to
know
how many ukrainians have to die because
of your government this liberal
government
enabling of gas prom to put more money
into Putin's War Machine
and I just uh take that question because
um I I think Mr bazan you actually
misunderstand a lot of the things that
are going on not at all Mr Richardson
government actually proposed an
alternative route for the for the gas to
actually flow through Ukraine that was
their proposal that would have had zero
impact on the dollars that actually
accrued to Russia because it still would
have been Russian gas it was flowing
through the alternative pipeline
um at the end so let's say this Mr
Wolfson responsible for natural
resources
European Union right now
um then you need to be able to explain
to the Germans and the French and the
Italians how they're going to survive
the winter like it's very easy to make
those kinds of comments and I would say
perhaps you can put this on so then
you're saying that the conservative
party would not have returned the
turbines I think it's important for
Canadians to understand that that's the
position of the Conservative Party of
Canada is that the position
well I think that what you just
mentioned is that Ukraine had another
option why didn't you fulfill that
option and sit on the on the turbines
we actually worked with the
International Energy agency to see how
viable that option was and it was not
viable in terms of flowing the amounts
of gas that would be required it
actually would require that we have
faith in Russia
let me ask you this question Mr chair if
you did your diligence
they don't want to answer the questions
I want to know
I'm the one asking I'm asking the
questions here you guys are the witness
I'm sorry yeah how many more atrocities
are you prepared to witness in Ukraine
because of the extra dollars you guys
are putting into Putin's war machine so
uh James it's true
your five minutes is up uh Mr Sarai of
the four five minutes
thank you thank you chair my first
question is to Mr uh Wilkinson were
alternative pipeline Roots uh through UK
Ukraine considered as being proposed by
Ukraine officials according to reports
yeah thank you for the question Randy
Ukrainian officials did propose an
alternative route for pipelines running
through Ukraine itself we reviewed that
option by the Ukrainian government with
technical experts from the International
Energy agency we also discussed it with
the European Union and with Germany the
issue is complex and involved
consideration of a number of technical
issues but the bottom line is that the
flows that could be expected to move to
Germany through the pipelines that run
from Russia via Ukraine would be
significantly lower than what nordstream
when operating at or close to full
capacity can move and in fact
significantly less than what flowed
through Nordstrom in 2021 but in
addition to the technical limitations
there were two other difficulties one is
you would have to believe that Russia
would be willing to flow significant
incremental gas flows through Ukraine
and given that Russia has already
reduced flows via Ukraine and it stated
that its view is the technical capacity
of the pipeline is actually only a third
of what the ukrainians believe it is the
likelihood of Russia not doing this is
is not high and for Germany and other
European countries let's be let's be
clear or the they currently rely on gas
from Russia the the idea of essentially
enabling the shutdown of nordstream one
and relying completely on pipelines that
run through what is presently a war zone
would come with enormous risk for their
economies and their citizens so yes we
looked at it and at the end of the day
we deemed and the International Energy
agency deemed it was not viable
thank you Minister Wilkinson I'm going
to ask the department of Deputy Minister
Morgan is there can you re please
reiterate what Global Affairs Canada if
it was aware of any kill list that
targeted locally engaged staff working
at the Canadian embassy in Ukraine
uh thank you Mr chair just to
re-emphasize what Minister Jolie said
earlier we take the security of all of
our staff at our missions abroad
extremely seriously we're constantly
monitoring the security situation and
communicating regularly with staff
including our locally engaged staff we
are not aware of any list specifically
targeting locally engaged staff at the
Canadian embassy in Kiev and we've made
maintained constant communication with
that locally engaged staff since before
Russia's invasion of Ukraine and
subsequently and continue to take many
actions to ensure that they can work
safely that they can work remotely and
that they maintain their strong
connection to our Embassy and are able
to deliver the vital work that they do
on behalf of us
thank you Deputy Minister Morgan my next
question is to administer Jolie Minister
Julie has any of Canada's sanctions
against uh Russia been designed to be
punitive in terms of humanitarian uh in
terms of any humanitarian needs of
either the Russians or any of the
neighboring countries such as Germany or
are they designed to economically and
militarily sanction Russia only but when
it comes to food supply medicine uh what
is Canada's position been or the energy
needs uh of those in Russia or around
Russia
so there's a couple of things on that
first of foremost the sanctions are
really to make sure that we're we're
putting maximum pressure on Russia and
and Putin's regime and that's why at
this point we're at a thousand six
hundred entities and and individuals uh
what we've been clear within the G7 is
that since Russia is weaponizing food
and Heather referred to it 40 million
lives are at risk of hunger of famine
right now we work among the the G7 to
make sure that our sanctions were not
affecting uh also the fact of exporting
grain exporting food to uh different
Middle Eastern country Lebanon being an
example Egypt or uh African countries
the Senegal Etc or again
um uh in Asian countries this has been a
a Paramount priority for the G7 there's
been many occasions where we reiterated
that the sanctions regimes were not
the the the fact that there was a food
crisis was not linked to sanctions but
rather linked to Putin's war of choice
in Ukraine and that is a message that
the Prime Minister and I uh clearly
stated not only at the Commonwealth but
also following the G7 NATO and I did so
also at the UN
thank you Mr Julie I don't know my time
if I have a time for another question it
would be to miss your 22 seconds
Mr Wilkinson uh can you uh tell us what
Canada is doing to support its European
allies in order to transition away from
Russian energy
sure we announced uh that we were
expanding production of oil and gas by
300 000 barrels by the end of the year
we are set up working groups with
European union and with Germany to focus
on both liquid natural gas opportunities
but also hydrogen opportunities as the
they look to both displace but also move
on the energy transition to address
domestic energy security and climate
change thank you Minister Mr sharai Mr
Bergeron you have the floor for two and
a half minutes
thank you Mr chair
I will come back to Mr Wilkinson on
the Ukrainian alternative I would like
to hear you explain that in more detail
to us but
before that
we have heard from many experts in the
media
who said that the Simmons turbines were
absolutely not necessary to ensure the
proper functioning of North stream 1.
and that other models could have been
easily done the job to allow Russia
to supply
gas to Germany and others
so did your department take this
information into account
and could other turbines have replaced
Siemens as turbines and do you think
that Russia
does not have any other turbines in
reserve
no there are six turbines that exist in
North stream one
and of course there are some turbines
used as replacement when there's a
problem or when they need to do turbine
maintenance
of course
the turbines that are now in use
in this pipeline are made by Siemens
and there is a contract between Siemens
and gas prom to for the maintain for the
maintenance of these turbines
I'm trying to
find the expression in French for uh why
he was looking to essentially reduce gas
flows which was that he did not have
access in his view to the turbines at
the end of the day you know if if uh if
we return the turbine and gas flows
actually returned to higher levels that
would be a very good outcome but at the
end of the day if we return the turbines
and that did not affect gas flows it
essentially is calling Putin's Bluff he
cannot blame Canada he cannot blame
Western Europe for the fact that that
there are no gas flows there and that
maintains the solidarity of the alliance
and that was the context in which we
made the decision
Stefan
can I add a comment Stefan
minutes
so our next round is Miss McPherson for
two and a half minutes you have the
floor Miss McPherson thank you Mr chair
um these are very short rounds
um Minister Julie I'm going to ask some
questions now if I could about the
embassy staff in Ukraine so I we have
heard that the deputy Minister was
unaware of of
um any specific uh kill lists but were
you aware of intelligence briefing from
the five eyes that said Embassy staff
may be included on lists not
specifically but maybe
I had not I never had that information
Heather and I I think that we need to
get to the bottom of the story because I
think Canadians need to know and of
course I want to make sure that we shed
light on this story so
yes
will you release the committee
correspondence like the the emails the
memos the notes notes will you share
that between the global Affairs Canada
and the Diplomatic staff in Ukraine will
you share that with us so we can we can
play our role as as parliamentarians
yeah so my goal is definitely that you
can all play your role as
parliamentarians I I think that since
this is intelligence information which
is linked to a war right now so I I my
suggestion is should parliamentary
parliamentarian be interested we could
definitely have the national uh security
and intelligence Committee of
parliamentarians study this issue and of
course I would make myself available
because it is very important that
Canadians know that the government of
Canada was there to protect not only
Canadian diplomats but also locally
engaged staff so so you didn't get
information from the five eyes which is
of course quite worrying because we we
would hope that some of that information
would be available but more importantly
I guess for for looking forward as as
you've you've mentioned
um we know that this this
um this happens because there was a memo
put in place by Stephen Harper in 2014
that denied locally engaged staff a duty
of care will you immediately rescind
that 2014 memo and issue a new memo
stating that Canada does have a duty of
care towards locally engaged staff so
this kind of betrayal doesn't happen
ever again well Heather in the context
particularly of of what was happening in
Ukraine we went above what was
technically did the Jew of care because
we wanted to make sure that uh since uh
lives could be a at risk because the the
the threat the of invasion was real
eminent we offered a Canadian locally
engaged staff to come to Canada some
have come some have decided to stay in
Ukraine we also offered them to work
from outside of Kiev even though the
Canadian diplomats had left and also we
offered but it is worth noting that that
didn't look natural thank you Miss
McPherson
sorry to interrupt Mr genuis you have
the floor for five minutes thank you
chair I'm going to follow up on the
Globe and Mail story about the locally
engaged staff at the Canadian embassy uh
Minister the source for the globe story
is three separate Canadian diplomats
with direct knowledge of these events
now you've offered
um a very qualified denial of the story
you've said that you you were not aware
of kill lists that specifically named
Canadians but that was not the question
and that was not the Globe and Mail
story their story was that Canadian
embassy staff were likely on lists and
that the five eyes
briefed Canadian officials that
ukrainians who worked for Western
embassies were likely on the list and
further that the Canadian embassy made a
decision not to pass that information
along so minister to be very clear is
the Globe and Mail story in your view
correct or not
well what I can tell you is that I
didn't have that information
the my team didn't have that information
you heard the deputy that the department
didn't have that information so we need
to get to the bottom verify what do you
mean by the department didn't have that
information
no employee of the Canadian government
we had information who's we though we so
it's my myself
my political staff and Global Affairs
Canada according to what the deputy has
just mentioned we had no information
regarding the fact that there was lists
specifically targeted Canadian diplomats
and locally engaged Staffing but that is
is not the question the Globe and Mail
story said that five eyes gave a brief
to the Canadian embassy that it was
likely that West that Ukrainian
Nationals who were locally engaged staff
working at Western embassies were likely
on the list can you please just give us
a clear answer
but I can tell you what I can tell you
is
yes or no what I can tell you is that
indeed and and the Americans made that
intelligence public
there were some lists specifically
targeting Russia uh Ukrainian people in
Ukraine brain and of course were
preoccupied with these targeting now in
the context of having any information
regarding Canadians being on these lists
Canadian diplomats locally engaged staff
we had no information regarding this and
so that is why it's really important
that Canadians be clear on that because
of course it is about the government of
Canada's responsibility towards not only
the people that work for us but people
also that are serving well thank you
Minister I I asked a clear question
I have the floor we had we had three
diplomats uh speaking to the Globe and
Mail potentially at some risk to their
own careers
uh yeah I'm sure because I think it's
very important that we get to the bottom
of this story uh Minister because
five
times
it was a clear question I asked you
which was whether or not the Globe and
Mail story is correct according to your
information you chose not to answer it
according to my information
thank you
Mr chair
point
well I hate to interrupt my colleague
but I was under the impression that this
meeting this session would be mainly on
the authorization allowing the transfer
of turbines to Germany
I know that
the question of relevance is interpreted
very widely it has been the case until
now but I'd like that I'd like us to
come back to the core subject at hand Mr
chair
uh it's a very good point uh Mr I have
my hand up on a point of order as well
is it on the same point of order it is
yeah okay uh please proceed Mr McPherson
thank you thank you Mr chair and I I
appreciate your comment Mr Bergeron but
I do just wanted to highlight that the
the members of the government had
brought this this issue up during their
questions already so I think it is it is
fair I would like to see obviously a
little bit more decorum within our
committee where we are not speaking over
each other
um so if that could be could be managed
Mr chair I think that would be great but
I do think it is reasonable for us for
us to ask these questions they are they
are they are relevant and they are
timely because of course the the
government has had an opportunity to ask
those questions already thank you
um as chair of course I would like
people to stay on topic although
historically there's been a fairly wide
latitude when it comes to these types of
things and I do recall at the beginning
of Minister's release statement she said
that we're here to discuss purton's war
of choice so I'm presuming uh other
topics uh related to The Invasion the
brutal Invasion by Russia are in order
Mr genius I have you uh you can have the
floor I have you uh with one more minute
left
thank you Mr chair and I would like to
provide a notice of motion to the
committee that the committee requests
that all documents in the possession of
the government related to the assessed
risk to non-canadians employed to the
Canadian diplomatic missions in Ukraine
at any time in the last 18 months be
provided to the committee within 30 days
of the adoption of this motion that's a
notice of motion I'm not moving it uh
additionally uh just in the time I have
left I've been struck by all this talk
about the Allies the alliance being
united about how we need to have the
alliance
um United Minister Jolie very directly
is Ukraine an ally of Canada in your
view
of course so the alliance is divided
no
so Ukraine is taking a very directly and
sharply a different position from Canada
clearly the alliance is divided if
Ukraine is part of the alliance
is that not
no I don't think that the alliance is
divided I think we have to be steadfast
in your uni sometime is Ukraine part of
the alliance Master you want me Garnet
to answer your questions or do you want
to Cuff me off at every time minister is
Ukraine part of the island that's my
question
Alliance
Ukraine is an ally and we are all
standing with Ukraine and our goal is to
continue to support them but now maybe
we'll be able to get an answer from you
because James didn't answer beforehand
is it the position of the Conservative
Party of Canada that the turbine should
not have been sent back to Germany thank
you uh Minister I would love to answer
that you're around us up unfortunately
Mr Janice
um Mr serberry of the floor for five
minutes
uh thank you cherish great to see you
Marty and great to see my colleagues
today uh it's ironic that the
conservatives would bring up the issue
and say talk about division on a day
when Canada announced that it'd be
sending 225 of our Canadian Armed Forces
over to Europe to help train the
Ukrainian soldiers fight Putin's unjust
unwarranted unprovoked uh war against
the Ukrainian people and we will always
stand with Ukrainian people uh Stan
shoulder to shoulder and side by side as
we continue this journey together and
it's going to be a long one and when I
use a use the word long specifically
because I do wish to talk about uh on
July 16
2022 Joseph Joseph Burrell uh put out a
Blog and Joseph Burrell is the high
representative of the EU for foreign
affairs and security policy and on this
blog he commented that for the need of
strategic patience
strategic patients being the need for
Europe to transition away from Russian
energy dependence whether it's oil gas
and even to a certain extent cool and
transition to to Alternative suppliers
including many countries uh in Africa
the Middle East including Kazakhstan as
well for some energy consumers including
Italy and Germany uh and also for Canada
to play a role in that transition is
obviously a green transition so I do
wish to ask first to minister Wilkinson
how is Canada
I don't say positioning itself because
it has been doing so for many years but
specifically on LNG front how is Canada
specifically aiding Europe on its
transition to a more secure
democratically oriented suppliers of
energy and also to the transition to
Green then I'll have a follow-up
question for Minister Jolie please
uh thank you Mr savara
um so let me let me start by saying
Europe is very focused on essentially
moving away from Russian oil and gas
they've set a Target that by the end of
this year they will affect found ways to
uh to move away from oil and ideally
Germany has said by the end of 2024 or
thereabouts they will be off of Russian
gas and of course they've made progress
along the way
um Canada is certainly uh working with
Germany and with the European Union to
be a part of helping them to do that
um and part of that is the expansion of
oil and gas production that we are
working on right now with the sector and
we are on track with with respect to the
additional 300 000 barrels a day which
will help in terms of increasing Supply
around the world we also as you know
have two LNG facilities in western
Canada one which is under construction
one which has other one which has been
approved and and apparently construction
will start next year which will
additionally provide supplies onto the
market which again will help with
respect to uh to displacing Russian gas
we're looking at a number of potential
sites in Eastern Canada
um that could meet the window let's be
clear it has to be something that can be
done within the next three or four years
or it will be outside the window of what
what will help Europe along this way but
we're also working with Europe on other
elements which are the transition part
of it which is hydrogen enormous work
going on in Newfoundland Labrador
example on hydrogen which will be used
to displace gas and eventually will
actually displace gas entirely as they
work towards the 2045 Net Zero
commitment that Germany has so Canada is
intimately engaged as you know the
German Chancellor is visiting us uh
later this month and the head of the
European Union is coming a month after
that to have exactly these conversations
thank you Minister Wilkinson and over to
minister Joe Lee Mr Julie for the last
48 hours or so you've met with your
German equivalent and counterpart I
would like you to touch upon these
discussions because unity and the
relationship between Canada the European
Union Canada Europe and obviously Canada
Germany is so important and I would like
to hear some color on those
conversations please
yes thank you thank you Francesco I I
think there's a reckoning on the part of
the
um
German government that uh for too long
they relied on cheap uh gas and that uh
therefore uh the conditions have
completely changed and that we need to
do more French Shoring and we need to
more to work more uh amongst allies when
it comes to energy when it comes to
critical minerals
um and so that's why there's a lot of
openness on the part of Germany
to invest in Canada to do so in a way
also that it is in line with our climate
uh agenda and that is why it is yes
about liquefied natural gas like
mentioned uh by Jonathan but also a lot
about hydrogen and the type of hydrogen
so green nitrogen and so I think while
Germany is looking at dealing with its
own energy security issue right now it
is also looking at doing the green
transition
quicker than expected and at the same
time what is happening amongst Europe is
that there is now a clear solidarity
approach when it comes to dealing with
Russian gas so all 26 members will be
there to support a country should it
have a energy capacity issue and so
we are also working with the Americans
to find Solutions the question of energy
security has never been so uh
Central to our foreign policy and that's
why Jonathan and I talk to each other
pretty much every day thank you Minister
thank you Mr Baron now I understand that
uh the next round is mine so I will pass
the chair to our second Vice chair Mr
Bergeron do you accept the chair will we
be issue
yes of course Mr chair so Mr Mirage you
have the floor for five minutes
uh thank you Mr Bergeron
um uh Mr Wilkinson
um I keep asking what the conservatives
would have done I'll tell you what the
conservatives would have done they
wouldn't have done everything in their
power over the last seven years to
absolutely kill the oil and gas industry
in Canada so that deaf spots like vladim
Putin could uh could could hold uh
extreme sorry the European Union for
ransom under circumstances like this and
particularly since 2014 it should have
been clear to your government that we
should have been expanding our oil and
gas exportation capacity Canada produces
the most has the most ethical energy
industry in the world and yet we can't
help the European Union can we because
we're not in a position to export LNG to
the European Union so you weren't in a
position to offer that isn't that right
minister
well I think it's important that we
actually look at the facts um if you
look at production levels with respect
to the oil and gas industry in Canada
they have gone up significantly over the
last number of years
um as you know LNG Canada is on the in
the process of being constructed so is
the Trans Mountain pipeline expansion so
there's been significant work to expand
the role that Canadian Oil and Gas
actually plays in the context of the
world economy but it's also important to
remember that climate change is actually
real it's not going away it is an
existential threat to the future of the
human race and we need to ensure that
we're addressing both of those together
we are doing exactly that through the
emissions reduction work that we're
doing with the oil and gas sector and so
I would say we've been doing exactly
what it is that Canadians should expect
their government you're not answering
the question wouldn't it be better to be
able to supplant despotic oil like
Vladimir Putin's oil with ethically
produced Canadian gas if basically your
government are you asking about oil or
are you asking about no I'm sorry
thank you for the clarification in this
case we're talking talking about natural
gas we could have been in a position to
supply and that natural gas to Germany
but we're not if you're a government had
taken that uh seriously after 2014 we
would be in a position that's what
conservatives would have done
conservatives wouldn't do what you're
implying is to let Germans freeze now
the other piece of this is this
um was there a question in there no just
a statement oh okay um so
um the executives of gas prom basically
come out and said that Mr markalov I
believe has come out and said that it's
not really about getting the turbine
back it's about it's about sanctions so
and and Chancellor Schultz has himself
said that um you know we're calling
Putin's Bluff so no one really ever
thought that this was about increasing
gas supply for Germany so it's not fair
of you to imply that conservatives would
let Germans freeze in the cold who is
letting Germans freeze in the coldest
your government for failing to expand
our export capacity for for LNG
um now my question is this have you had
any discussions with the German
government before you authorize the
release of the turbines to supply them
with Canadian LNG
we've been having conversations uh for a
significant time with the uh not only
with the Germans but with the European
Union about how Canada can assist with
energy requirements going forward that
could include uh liquid natural gas
um if it if it can fit within the time
frame where you know they are looking to
make the transition it also certainly
involves hydrogen and there are many
active proposals that are going on with
respect to hydrogen but yes we have
active working groups how long will both
the European Union and Germany how long
will it take before in our position to
provide our Canadian LNG to to the
European Union well that is partly up to
the government it's partly up to the
proponents so the proponents that are
looking at the various facilities on the
East Coast have not yet come to the
point where they've made some kind of an
FID a final investment do you think you
should start when you're working
actively with them to try to actually
help them navigate through what may be
regulatory issues uh we are also working
with them to partner with the Germans
and the Europeans the private sector
needs to bring Capital to the table last
question actually can uh can put it to
work last question and I'll pass the mic
do you think if you had started in 2014
after Mr Putin made his intentions clear
by invading and taking over Crimea that
you'd be in a position today to solve
this problem for Germany and not have to
send turbines to Mr Putin so he can make
more money to fund his war effort no I
think I think Mr morantz you've got to
actually look at some of the fundamental
economics I mean Russian gas was always
going to be cheaper and up until the the
Ukrainian Invasion it has become you
know it it was an issue of Germany
looking for the cheapest source of of
gas Canada's competitive Advantage with
respect to gas is actually very much on
the west coast where there's a much
shorter amount of transmission transport
that actually is required that is why
LNG Canada has been moving forward over
the last number of years that is why
wood fiber has moved forward but
certainly the energy security issues
have changed the dynamic and it's not
just about cheap Russian oil and gas
anymore and that is exactly what is
motivating some of the interest on the
east coast to to look at opportunities
in Germany well I put it to you that
it's your government's uh failed energy
policies
I am handling the chair back to you
thank you very much Mr Bergeron Mr
zuberi uh you have the floor for five
minutes thank you Mr Marans and Messiah
I'd like to also thank the ministers who
are with us today just um put forth a
question to uh the Minister of Foreign
Affairs
um in terms of the rhetoric we've been
hearing a lot of rhetoric from
opposition members around uh what's been
happening with respect to the turbines
and the Ukrainian governments I'd like
to ask you um has this recent incident
has it caused any true strain in the
relationship between the Ukrainian
government and us uh
if you could please comments
I think that we have been actively
engaged with the Ukrainian government we
can't hear you oh can you hear me now
can you hear me
okay
okay summer can you hear me
Mr clerk what does the status of our
Communications
um I'm sorry I was somebody was asking
me it's good sorry it's good so it's
good yeah
thank you okay
okay so
um of course
um we had many conversations with the
Ukrainian government there's a very open
uh channel of communication I I speak to
the Chief of Staff of
um of uh president zielinski andremak uh
on uh on on a very uh very often
um on a regular basis uh also with my
counterpart dimitro culeba foreign
affairs minister as you saw also the
Prime Minister hasn't had many
conversations with uh president zidinski
and of course this was a very difficult
decision summer you you heard that uh
I've said it many times and I truly uh
uh feel it and believe it because there
was a lot of time Jonathan and I spent
into this issue but that being said uh
we announced something very important
today which is the resumption of uh
operation unifier 225 CAF members going
to to train ukrainians as they're
fighting a very existential war and so
we will continue to have strong
sanctions make sure that we send Heavy
Artillery that we're there also in terms
of review manager and Aid and were there
also to provide the right support to
ukrainians in these difficult times
thank you and a second question you
talked about
industry foreign
you mentioned the importance of
maintaining the unity of the alliance in
response to the Russian invasion can you
talk to us about some difficulties that
you envisage as we are heading into a
new phase of the war thank you Samir I
think we have to make sure that there is
no fatigue
when it comes to the support in this war
we know that when it comes to news about
Ukraine they're still important but
they're not as important as they were at
the beginning of the war and there are
other Stakes that come into play but so
we have to make sure that Canadians are
constantly and always interested and
informed about what's going on and we
have to make sure that other countries
the Americans Germans the French the
British do the same it is very important
that within our democracies we have
strong support we will continue to work
with Ukrainian organizations I know
Alexandra is here with us on my screen
so I'd like to salute her we will
continue to work with other Regional
organizations too and naturally we will
be there to support them as I was saying
there will be additional sanctions that
will be announced there will be
additional support that will be
announced so we continue our support
thank you madam Minister
um given the current situation in Europe
and Canada standing as a net energy
exporter
in terms of
providing
um uh energy to become the energy
provider of choice to to Europe what are
we doing either unilaterally or with
America in order to position ourselves
as such
well certainly Canada is looking to
ensure that we are participating in
helping our European friends as they
transition off of Russian oil and gas I
spoke earlier about the incremental 300
000 barrels of oil and gas that we
committed to work with the industry to
ensure that we achieve by the end of the
year and we are on track to do that we
are working on uh on LNG opportunities
in the east coast we have a couple of
opportunities on the west coast that
will also help in terms of increasing
Supply in the world but we're also very
very focused on hydrogen which is going
to be the energy carrier of the future
as we move to transition to address the
climate issue but ensure that we
actually have reliable sources of energy
and Canada is blessed with the
opportunity to produce hydrogen in
different kinds of ways derived from
natural gas derive from electricity and
electrolysis in a manner that Canada can
be a hydrogen superpower to the world as
we move forward and so we are looking at
all of those things the short-term
opportunities to assist and the longer
term opportunities to be a dominant
player on a go forward basis thank you
Minister now it looks like like we have
time just for one more five minute uh uh
session uh Mr genius you have the floor
no I think the block
point of order Mr chair
case I've received from the uh from the
clerk perhaps the clerk could clarify
the second and following rounds of
questions it says
five minutes for the conservative party
liberal five minutes and then 2.5 block
do from 2.5 in DP and then five and five
and then back to a third round five
minutes for conservatives we are in the
third round
we have finished the second round so it
was conservative liberal block NDP
conservative liberal and second round we
start again conservative liberal and so
on and so forth
so this is the motion that was adopted
at the first meeting
so we are now going to continue with the
block
so conservative 45 minutes a liberal
Vlog quebecois NDP conservative liberal
this is the round and then you we
restart with the conservatives
correct
Mr clerk we've started the third round
so I don't really follow your reasoning
is
it's not my reasoning it's the motion
that was adopted this is not my
committee but I think this is the motion
that was adopted at the first meeting so
this indicates the order
um so as I was saying conservative
liberal in Block NDP conservative
liberal and then we restart if I can
after Madam McPherson we had a we had
five minutes for Mr genus and then there
was five minutes for the Liberals and
then another five minute round
given to Mr morans and then another five
minutes given to the Liberals and
normally I should have my two and a half
minutes
I am following the order that you
mentioned
so we've done two five minute rounds
it's The Minister's uh 128 if the
ministers will indulge Us by staying for
five minutes let's do two two and a half
minute rounds then one for Mr Bergeron
and one for Miss McPherson and that'll
cap off The Minister's meeting is that
uh work for everybody fine Minister we
started five minutes late I wonder can
we just finish the third round or I mean
I think it is Mr Bergeron's turn but I
just wonder if we can finish the third
round
I have a hard end I I can stay for an
extra couple of minutes to finish the
the two and a half two and a half which
I think is fair because the block and
and the NDP didn't get uh anything in
the third round but I have a hard end so
okay so um Mr Bergeron you have the
floor for two and a half minutes
thank you Mr chair first off I would
like to
let my colleagues know that uh
interrupting each other and just eating
into each other's speaking time has been
giving our interpreters a hard time so
if we can avoid doing that for the rest
uh Mr Wilkinson when you answered my
question
about the different types of turbines
that could potentially work in North
stream one you finished by saying by
referring to Unity but we have Rick
Taylor a retired General is warning us
that this decision risked weakening the
Western sanctions regime and we are
seeing that Hungary
is taking a step they
might actually have an increased supply
of natural gas delivery and they opposed
the European plan for the reduction of
natural gas consumption so is this not a
first break if you will in the common
front of Western Nations on the one hand
and on the other hand if you can give us
a bit more detail on the Ukrainian
proposal of having the advantage of
providing gas and oil supply for Ukraine
while at the same time
given of course a common front of the
European countries that would have
forced Putin's hand
if if he went on to supply Europe or
completely cut off supply for Europe
you asked many questions yes I had
limited time
what I would like to say is that
it is very important to support the
unity of our allies and also to support
the Ukrainian people so we have taken
steps
to make sure that we can support Ukraine
you refer to Mr Hillier
but maybe you forgot the two others Mr
Wesley Clark and Mr David Petraeus who
declared their support for Canada's
decision
as I've already mentioned they said that
it is very important that we are united
and together with our allies
to make sure
that we can all together support Ukraine
and that's exactly what we did with this
decision
A4 for the last two and a half minutes
thank you very much Mr chair so so I'm
going to ask some very very quick
questions of Minister Jolie if I could
um I don't know that we got the clarity
that we needed to with regards to
um to the Embassy staff in Ukraine so so
the global global mail is standing by
its reporting today and it spoke to
Ukrainian staff and and this is what
they said and I quote the Ukrainian
staff members some of whom have returned
to their posts in Kiev said that they
could not respond to requests for
comment because of an internal hunt to
find the globe's unnamed sources so
several said they were afraid speaking
out would cost them their jobs I just
would like yes or no is there an
internal hunt to find these
whistleblowers at this time um Mr Julie
no Heather because there's no need for a
whistle blowing thank you and then the
second question is um will you and I
don't think I got an answer on this when
I asked in the last session but will you
immediately rescind the 2014 Harper era
memo that denies locally engaged staff a
duty of care and issue a new memo
stating that Canada does have a duty of
care so indeed there's an issue with the
Harper approach when it comes to gdf
care and that's problematic and we've
seen it in the context of Ukraine so
what I uh will do is definitely in the
context of uh addressing the issue we
will use the future of diplomacy process
that is undergoing to make sure that we
study it and that we make sure that we
abide by our moral obligations to be
there for locally engaged staff to be
foreign
that you've already said that it's wrong
it's a it's a wrong it's a bad memo it's
a bad policy you have the ability to
rescind that policy right this minute
you could do that and that would protect
staff around the world that work well
Heather actually it's in the legislation
of 2014 so obviously this there would be
a need to change that legislation that's
why we have to do it it's a memo and you
could do it so so I'm going to ask
another couple questions yeah go ahead
in with regards to the sanctions and I
know it's so fast I apologize with
regards to the sanctions I have put
forward a study so that we can do a
follow-up study to the 2017 committee
study on Canada sanctions regime I think
we're all very worried that sanction
regime is not transparent it is not
enforceable it is not being done
properly so I would like to bring the
cbsa the RCMP National Security folks to
talk about the sanctions issues and to
discuss the threats of the threats to
Canadians into our to our national staff
abroad but I'm just wondering if you
would agree given that there is so many
problems with our sanctioned regime that
an annual report one of the
recommendations from the 2017 study
would be a good idea
well you know I haven't read directly
the 2017 report I'll we'll look into it
and I look forward to talking to you
about it for sure thank you Minister and
thank you to both ministers for your
time and answering our questions today
it's very much appreciated we're going
to suspend for a couple of minutes do a
sound check for Miss kichi from the UCC
and we will pick it up then
thank you
representative from the Ukrainian
Canadian Congress uh Alexandra kichi
president of the Ukrainian Congress
appearing uh virtually uh Ms kichi uh
please proceed with your opening
statement for five minutes thank you Mr
chair members of the committee I would
like to thank you for the opportunity of
addressing you on the
162nd day of the war in Ukraine uh every
morning since February 24th I have been
checking my phone and giving silent
thanks that none of my friends or family
were killed overnight and then after I
checked my phone I ask myself what am I
going to do today to end Russia's war
against Ukraine so today what I am doing
is testifying before you on July 28th
Russian social media channels posted a
video of a Russian soldier castrating a
Ukrainian pow the next day Russian
occupation forces in olanyuka murdered
over 50 Ukrainian pows a week before
that the Russians bombed the port of
Odessa from which grain was to be
exported and the week before that the
Russians bombed a shopping center in
vindicza and before that Clement
evidence of mass rape of civilians women
girls and boys has been collected and
documented
in March after the Russians retreated
Mass Graves of civilians were found in
bucha I visited butcher in June and what
I saw I assure you I will never forget
I could go on but suffice to say that
we've all had a front seat uh view in
our living rooms that where we witnessed
the horror of what Russia is doing in
Ukraine and since February 24th Russia
has earned over a hundred billion euros
in revenue from fossil fuels 60 percent
of that came from the EU this is
untenable tenable this is the financing
of genocide so today I ask you members
of the committee the same question that
I ask myself what will you do today to
end Russia's war against Ukraine
the Ukrainian Canadian Congress asks
that you do the following that you call
on the government of Canada to revoke
the permit that allows the ongoing
servicing of turbines that enable
Russia's terrorist war machine to
function and to restore full sanctions
against gospel and why do we suggest
that because it's absolutely clear that
Russia contrived the north stream one
debacle to test the resolve of Germany
Canada and our allies on sanctions and
we have failed that test Germany and
Canada did not understand what the test
was it's about sanctions the unity on
sanctions not just on North stream one
but on the Ultimate Prize Nordstrom 2
Putin has not given up on that so when
Chancellor Schultz says that he called a
bluff he called the wrong Bluff
but nonetheless he's received a response
and now the choice is clear it's time to
restore those sanctions as you know the
UCC opposed and continues to oppose the
waiver of sanctions on gospel and indeed
the waiver of any sanctions as they
relate to Russia and its genocidal war
in Ukraine it's been the long-standing
position of the UCC that's seeking to
accommodate or placate Russia only
emboldens them the Russian regime
responds only to strength we know this
because of events in the past by
Russia's war against Ukraine in the
present and will be borne out in the
future as well unless we collectively
put an end to this and Mr sorbara that
Journey can't be long because too many
ukrainians are dying every day so I
submit to you that there is no
reasonable justification for the
continuation of the waiver and there was
none when the decision was first taken
as you review the testimony before you
today I ask you to consider two things
did the government of Canada do
everything possible to avoid lifting
those sanctions did they leave any stone
unturned before capitulating to what
everyone knows was blackmail and
secondly is there an ongoing
justification to continue with the
waiver I believe that there were other
options that Canada and Germany could
have pursued but it appears that they
chose not to pursue them firstly we
already heard mention of the alternative
pipelines through Ukraine and Poland now
that would have been a bluff worth
calling to put that choice to Putin
but uh Minister Wilkinson has said that
that was not a viable choice but
ironically uh are they a better choice
than the 20 that gospel has now reduced
the flow to and we should also note that
those pipelines it running through
Ukraine are the only piece of
infrastructure that Russia has not yet
Bond ask yourselves why not
so uh there are also Alternative Energy
suppliers on the global market we have
not heard any evidence on that point and
it appears that Chancellor Schultz was
interested in only one alternative the
continued supply of cheap Russian gas
for two more years and through a gas
prom owned Pipeline and not any other
pipeline
as for the continuation of the permit in
light of what has transpired since July
9th we submit there is no justification
as was entirely predictable Russia did
not restore the gas flow and is now
demanding further concessions first the
papers weren't in order now the repairs
are defective this dance will continue
forever and frankly I am very troubled
by the ease with which the government of
Canada granted the turbine waiver it
does not instill confidence that further
concessions won't be granted and one of
the most important lessons that history
has taught us is that appeasement of
aggressors and dictators does not work
it has the opposite effect it emboldens
them appeasement is what got us here in
the first place after the West remains
silent on Georgia on chechnya Crimean
the donbass Syria on Salisbury and
countless other blatant violations of
international law by Russia and as NATO
secretary hence stoltenberg recently
stated if Ukraine loses it's a danger
for us it will make Europe even more
vulnerable to Russian aggression
so even if you don't care about the
moral aspect of this you should care
about your own security interest he went
on to say and so we must pay we must pay
for the support pay for the humanitarian
Aid and pay for the consequences of
economic sanctions because the
alternative is to pay a much higher
price later on yes we pay a price but
the right the price we pay is the EU and
NATO is a price we measure in money the
price ukrainians pay is measured in the
lives lost every day so it's time for
Canada and our allies to finally take
the upper hand in dealing with Russia
and to say no to Blackmail and stop
responding to their demands
thank you for the time thank you very
much Miss kichi I will go right to
um Mr bazan uh who has a six-minute
round Mr President of the floor thank
you Mr chair and I want to thank UCC
Alexandra for for appearing today uh
this is a very troubling time it's
embarrassing uh that the government can
uh capitulate it I appreciate uh your
your thoughts uh with everyone in
Ukraine and uh for your strong advocacy
on behalf of of Ukraine here in Canada
um so you talk about the sanctions
regime do you believe that this is a
thin edge of the wedge that could
potentially uh topple the entire
sanctions regime with the return of the
turbines and uh do you believe that
every time Putin wants to call his bluff
as Minister Wilkinson said uh that
Canada is going to be suckered in I I
think this is the first waiver of
sanctions that we have seen I think it
is uh the thin edge of the wedge and the
way to resolve it is to revoke that
permit and show Putin that he that the
West will not be toyed with
thank you
um now that
um more revenues are flowing back to
Russia because or potentially could flow
back to Russia With The Return of the
turbines do you believe Canada should be
increasing its military assistance to
Ukraine as well as humanitarian relief
we have always advocated for more and
continued
assistance to Ukraine we are of course
grateful for the support that the
government of Canada has provided to
date but the war is not over the
economic situation in Ukraine is
deteriorating they need more help and of
course on the military front the
ukrainians must be allowed to win this
war they're prepared to fight our fight
the West fight and the least we can do
is support them militarily
so you would agree uh or a UCC would
agree that military equipment like
sending the new sniper rifles that are
sitting at uh PGW defense in Winnipeg
should be purchased by the government
Canada and supplied to Ukraine or that
the armored ambulances that we have on
inventory that are about to retire
there's 32 Bisons that are configured as
armored ambulances that should be sent
to Crane to help save lives or that the
soon to be retired vehicles uh light
armored vehicles that we have the entire
fleet coyotes and bison's and m113s
track labs are all about to be retired
are those the things that Canada should
be
supplying right now to Ukraine then that
Canada has dragged its feet on Mr bazan
I never thought that I would have to
learn the language of war or understand
military procurement
and it pains me every day that I have to
do that
um I don't pretend to be a military
expert uh when we are asked these
questions we defer to our Embassy in
Ottawa to assist us in understanding
what the needs of Ukraine are all I can
say is if Canada has it we should send
it
thank you
um when we're looking at the atrocities
as you laid out
um and we talk about you know the
capitulation by the government of Canada
what should we be doing and aside from
you know revoking the the waiver and
reversing this this uh ill-advised
decision uh what should the government
account to be doing to ensure that those
that are responsible for the atrocities
and war crimes that we're witnessing uh
are brought to Justice
well I would we of course have the
international criminal court that has
taken steps in opened investigations
there is an ongoing there is ongoing
work with the office of the prosecutor
General personally I would like to see
Canada playing a greater role in the
prosecution of war crimes we are blessed
to have amongst us a prominent jurist
The Honorable Louise Arbor who has
direct experience in that she has
prosecuted a genocide in her lifetime
and I would encourage the government of
Canada to assign uh Madame Arbor to that
role to represent Canada in that effort
Mr chair um you know I think it's it's
um very uh unfortunate that uh we have
only invited UCC to be here for uh half
an hour when they are the leading voice
of uh the Ukrainian diaspora and those
of us of Ukrainian Heritage that live in
in Canada and they are so knowledgeable
on the crimes against humanity that
occur in Ukraine on what Ukraine needs
or communication with the government
crane so I'd like to move the following
that the committee invite the Ukrainian
Canadian Congress back to answer
additional questions on the matter
currently before the committee for an
additional hour before August the 20th
uh thank you Mr Roseanne uh we have a
motion on the floor uh does anyone wish
to speak to the motion
uh Mr chairman my hand is up in the room
uh oh uh miss Ben Diane uh you have the
floor
thank you Mr
fit
um it's very important to hear from the
UCC I'm certainly glad that they're
joining us here today I I think it's a
bit unfortunate actually that emotion
was moved by a conservative during the
ucc's testimony because it does take
away time from
um this important discussion
um and I I think we should maximize the
the amount of time that we have with the
with the Ukrainian Congress while they
they are with us and while I appreciate
um the suggestion it could something it
could be something that we deal with
when we don't have witnesses uh before
us so I would move to adjourn debate on
this motion
um sorry Mr clerk I'm going to need a
little assistance from you on this we
have a motion on the floor so we have to
vote uh we have to vote on that vote
during debate we have to vote on that
motion first since it's not debatable
so the motion for Mrs band Twitter and
debate
um
okay so uh sure so I call the question
is that uh yeah on this
okay uh all right uh so we're I'm going
to call a question on Miss Ben Diane's
motion
to adjourn debate on Mr pazan's motion
um so Mrs Ben and I'm Ben Diane
Mr sobara
Mr sidhu
in favor Mr Sarai
in favor
Mr zuberi
Mr leopard
opposed
Mr genius
no no excuse me
Mr Mr Bergeron
we I vote Yes
no
oh sorry I'm getting ahead of myself
sorry Jake I got I got left behind
so just to be clear Mr leopard voted no
okay it's just because it was yeah I I
voted
no no
Mr bezan
no
Mr genius you
I voted no
Mr Bergeron
we Mrs McPherson
no
so we have six years
four knees
so the emotion is uh has been approved
and a debate is now adjourned on Mr
bazan's motion Mr bezan I have I I think
roughly two minutes left in your round
please yield the floor please proceed
thank you Mr chair
um
just want to go back with UCC to talk
about
um you know the situation on the ground
uh if they can describe more detail uh
you know where
Ukraine needs more assistance and now
that Russia is receiving more revenues
or potentially more revenues through gas
prom uh how Canada can invest in Ukraine
to help them win this war
again uh
hearkening back to my earlier response I
am not a military expert but I do I'm
talking about just my military I'm
talking about the entire you know the
economy humanitarian assistance
infrastructure you know having a
Marshall Plan you know things along that
that line well obviously the The Avenues
that have been pursued by the Allies so
far I think where we could uh see more
is uh even greater sanctions I don't
believe that we have seen the sanctions
from hell that President Biden uh
forecast many months ago they seem to be
uh coming in uh spurts and I think that
they could be certainly more aggressive
and more comprehensive on the economic
support uh Ukraine has had to ask for a
waiver of interest payments on the
international debt that it owes
inflation is forecasted uh something
like sorry the contraction of the
economy is forecast at something like 40
percent
and Ukraine does need economic support
to keep small businesses going what I
Marvel at is the fact that there is any
business or any economy functioning at
all in these uh wartime conditions so
anything that we can do to assist on the
humanitarian Aid front uh while Canada
has welcomed I believe close to 50 000
ukrainians in the last few months there
is ongoing support that can be provided
to our allies in Europe where the bulk
of the displaced persons remain they are
reluctant to leave the continent
but there are other members who we have
such a short time uh so you know how
fast a half an hour goes by
um and so Mr sidhu is now up for six
minutes
let's just do you have the floor
great thank you uh thank you Mr chair
and uh I'll be splitting uh my time with
uh with my colleague Francesco sorbera
uh Miss kitchie thank you for for being
here with us today and for taking the
time
um to share some of your thoughts and
your statement uh today in this very
important meeting uh Miss kichi as you
may be aware just this week Canada
imposed further additional sanctions as
we continue to stand side by side uh
with Ukraine there is no doubt that
Canada will continue working with our
International partners and allies to
explore additional measures as stated by
Minister Jolie studies show that Russia
has lost companies worth nearly 40
percent of its GDP as a result of the
many sanctions imposed by Canada and our
allies given the significant volume of
sanctions announced it is sometimes
difficult to compare when it comes to
sanctions against Industries such as oil
and gas and luxury goods are you aware
of any other G7 countries that have
implemented as expensive measures as
Canada
uh I do not have uh our comparison chart
at hand our office does run that metric
and we can share it with the committee
if you like but one of the things that
Canada certainly could do that would uh
do more than actually sanctions is
declare Russia a state sponsor of
terrorism that would take care of a lot
of the issues that we are talking about
it would remove State immunity from
Russia and it would make them the Pariah
internationally that they deserve to be
Mr chairman okay to speak
well thank you Miss Kitty um as you just
mentioned uh you've called for Russia to
be declared a state sponsor of terrorism
uh Terror a designation Canada has only
ever used against Iran uh to your
knowledge have any other G7 governments
implemented implemented a similar
designation against Russia that debate
is ongoing uh south of our border our
American friends uh both houses uh are
considering a motion to do just that and
as Nancy Pelosi the speaker said if
Russia isn't on the list of state
terrorists then tear up the list
thank you Miss Kitty can you speak to
the importance of Canada sorry to speak
to the importance of Canada's continued
support for Ukraine uh in terms of
Financial and military aid and why it's
important Canadians not become fatigued
as this war drags on
because it's a war that Ukraine is
fighting for all Western democracies if
Ukraine loses this war as hence
stoltenberg said
eventually that war will bleed out to
Europe and Beyond and we know that from
Putin's statements you've all read his
manifestos where he foresees a
reconstitution not just of the former
Soviet Union but of the Russian Empire
and we know that the support of
Ukraine's neighbors is particularly
strong because they know that all that
stands between them and Putin are the
ukrainians
thank you Mr chair I'll turn the floor
over to to Francesco sorbero if you want
to turn the floor over
thank you Parliament parliamentary
secretary sidhu uh to the Ukrainian
Congress thank you for your testimony
today and uh obviously we want this uh
the war to come to an end as soon as
possible and for Ukraine to have its
territorially territorial sovereignty
and integrity uh protected and belonging
to the Ukrainian people and no one else
uh full stop uh in terms of the view in
the world uh in terms of our allies and
and working together uh wouldn't you
agree wouldn't you agree that it's
important for Canada continue to
continue working with our allies you
know you mentioned the United States the
United States did come out and say that
they supported our decision on the
turbines uh the Europeans said this the
the exact uh the same thing and in fact
uh moving the turbines back over to to
Mainland Europe were not actually impact
the amount of funds that Russia collects
uh those are governed under a contract
with with Europe I know MP bizan alluded
to this fact but I'm gonna have to
disagree with that that is my my
understanding of of the how that works
that it would not actually allow Russia
to gain any additional funds but and I
want to make that point but don't you
agree that Canada has been working with
its allies with Ukraine even today the
announcement of the Canadian Armed
Forces going over to the UK to again and
continue to assist the training of
Ukrainian soldiers in defending their
territorial Integrity of Ukraine
the Ukrainian Canadian Congress
certainly appreciates all of the
assistance that Canada and allies have
been providing but on this point we
respectfully disagree we believe that
this was a test of of Unity on sanctions
and we believe that this has created a
[ __ ] in the armor and it's not too late
to reverse that decision it is a
revocable permit and we call upon this
committee to ask the government of
Canada to revoke that permit we have not
heard what the Americans or any other
allies have said since July 9th when
we've seen the uh the result of the
return of that turbine
uh chair I'm finished in my line of
questioning thank you and thank you for
your attendance today Alexandra and
obviously uh God's blessings and God
speaks to the people of Ukraine thank
you
uh thank you uh Mr bear Mr Bergeron you
have the floor for six months
thank you Mr chair
well first of all
I would like to assure UCC that
they have our fullest support the vote
that took place a couple minutes ago
does not in any May way mean that we
don't want to hear you for longer it's
quite the contrary I made it clear to
the clerk and to the chair that half an
hour was not sufficient to have the
opportunity of talking to you having
said that I don't think that it is the
the appropriate means of doing this is a
last minute motion to impose witnesses
to members of this committee but with
that I am completely open to having of
course asking you to join us again as to
appear as a witness again
in the meantime maybe some progress will
have happened as well now you know that
all the sanctions imposed by the
European Union
that the European Union Roger
was careful to Target the energy Supply
coming from Russia it's a precaution
let's call this a precaution that that
Canada did not resort to when it decided
to introduce its sanctions regime which
led us to the situation in which Canada
found itself but
considering the fact that the European
Union was careful to avoid including in
its sanctions
all aspects that could touch energy
Supply coming from Russia do you believe
that this
precaution
would have nullified all the criticism
if you will that the government of
Canada's decision
could have allowed the supply of oil and
gas to Europe coming from Russia
and at the same time of course supplying
the Russian war machine
thank you Mr Bergeron for uh the
clarification with respect to the motion
I am always ready to to testify before
this committee and any other with regard
to the EU sanctions
um I believe that the EU will reconsider
its position uh given that we have now
seen Russia cut off Poland and Bulgaria
and Finland because they did stick to
the sanctions when they were called upon
to pay for Russian gas in Rubles they
took a principled position refused to do
so and Russia cut them off I understand
that Russia is now cutting off other
countries and strategically cutting off
other uh
businesses and and industries and it is
clear that Russia is engaging now in the
continuation of the gas Wars that they
have played for the last 30 years every
time there was a political problem with
Ukraine they would cut the gas off to
Europe so that the Europeans would
pressure the ukrainians but I think you
know when speaking of unity of the
Allies one of the principles of that is
that nothing about Ukraine without
Ukraine and the point was made earlier
with Madame Julie that ukrainians are
allies as well and there is no Unity on
that question with the ukrainians they
object to the waiver of those sanctions
Theo
if we
admit Canada's retention that this
authorization
[Music]
would have served to show moscow's real
motivation
and you heard Minister Wilkinson talking
about having gas go through a Ukrainian
Pipeline and you underlined that this
was the only infrastructure in Ukraine
which has yet to be bombarded why do you
believe that this infrastructure
is an alternative an interesting
alternative uh plausible and the valid
alternative
for the simple fact that it exists there
are pipelines through Ukraine and
through Poland that are alternatives to
Nord stream one if this was about the
turbine you avoid the question of the
turbine by using one of the other
pipelines if the question is about
sanctions though then you don't avoid
the question and I think it it has
always been about sanctions not about
the pipeline or the turbine and we
we have allowed ourselves Canada has
allowed itself to be party to Blackmail
that resulted in a waiver of those
sanctions
thank you Mr Bergeron uh now we have
Miss McPherson for six minutes
and that will bring us to the end of our
meeting with the UCC
thanks Mr chair
um and I and I would like to thank our
guest from the UCC and and just just
give my my heartfelt thanks for the the
work that you and and the entire
organization has been doing over the
last
um terrible terrible months as we as we
see what's happened in Ukraine I know
that not only are you expected to be the
voice of Ukrainian Canadians but you are
also dealing with the the horrific
burden of what we are watching happening
in Ukraine and your bravery is is
admirable so thank you thank you for
being here thank you for your voice
thank you for the work that you've done
to this point
um also very very keen on having you
come back and speak to the committee so
so I look forward to that opportunity
um I think I what I'd like to ask you
some questions just about the sanctions
regime itself so so yes I mean I think
we can we can look at what happened with
regards to the waiver
um and and you know say that basically
we've Now set up a system where where
Germans aren't any better off for the
weakening of our sanctions you know that
Putin has very clearly used this as a
tool to Blackmail our allies and
blackmail us
um and now there is it is it is proven
to have worked so why would he not use
this same system with regards to food
with regards to energy in other
countries you know he has as we know
weaponized food to the point where
millions of people's lives are at risk
um will he use this to chip away at our
sanctions so so it's a big worry that I
have and I just wonder from your
perspective if that's something that you
see if if you do have some worry about
about setting a precedent where we allow
a man like Vladimir Putin to Blackmail
Canada and to undermine our sanctioned
regime well absolutely and and that has
been the position of the UCC since
before the War Began we we warned uh in
the months leading up to the full-scale
invasion that uh strong deterrence was
the only way to to stop an invasion we
called for arming Ukraine for sanctions
before and unfortunately uh that only
started to happen in the days and and
leading up to the war Canada only uh
made the decision to send lethal weapons
some 10 days prior to the actual
Invasion and so
I I urge you all to become historians
students of history and understand
who we are dealing with ukrainians
unfortunately have lived with uh various
versions of Vladimir Putin for over 300
years and we know exactly how the psyche
works and deterrent appeasement does not
work with him only a strong hand will
show Putin that the West means what it
says and by caving on sanctions we are
showing him our weak
our weakness absolutely and I I'm sure
you were watching while the ministers
were here providing testimony for us and
and I did flag with Minister Jolie that
that I'm very concerned about how our
sanctions are being enforced the lack of
transparency so that parliamentarians
can see that Canadians can see what what
is being seized what those assets are
I've brought it up in the house a number
of times I've I've asked it in order
paper questions you know a perfect
example is that we learned yesterday
that the cbsa was able to stop a
shipment of dual use weapons to Russia
but that's the only one that they can
tell us any information about they can't
release details about any other any
other shipments and we also know from
John Iverson's story on July 21st that
Italian officials had seized
russian-bound drones sent via Canada and
that the cbsa missed that shipment so
I'm wondering if you feel that you know
when we when we hear the government talk
about the 1600 sanctions that they have
in place do you worry that it is
performative that this sanctioned regime
is in fact a performative thing where
they are saying the right things they
are telling us that the sanctions are in
place but there is no way for us to
check no way for Canadians to know if
they're working no way for us to to
measure the efficacy of that sanctioned
regime
um the UCC would certainly welcome a
greater transparency on sanctions
regimes since 2014 UCC called for the
imposition of strong sanctions for
following the invasion of Crimea and the
donbas and we did not see anything
particularly muscular coming from Canada
we urged at a minimum a mirroring of
what the Americans were doing what the
EU was doing so there we certainly would
welcome greater transparency and also
um we would like to see a beneficial
ownership registry of uh impo sorry in
Canada so that we could see who owns
what I mean the purpose of sanctions uh
is is to uh freeze those assets but I
think the next step and we've got the
legislation in place now is to to seize
them and sell them and that can only
happen if we know what we're looking for
and I think 120 million dollars of
seized assets is probably just the tip
of the iceberg in terms of what is uh
being controlled in Canada by Russians
and their proxies absolutely and I you
know I have heard from people who have
said that it is very difficult for us to
even understand the shipping between
Russia and and Canada and you know in
fact the the the the transparency of the
Russian Federation is higher than the
transparency of of the Canadian
government in terms of that so so
certainly I think there's a lot of work
that the Canadian government could do to
make sure that that that's in place and
I I agree with you that we 100 percent
need to to understand who is benefiting
from these I know there's these um
corporate relationships are very very
complex and and it will take
um you know some Specialists to do that
so I look forward to to working with the
minister and working with all my
colleagues to make sure that happens
thank you Ms McPherson and that brings
us to the end of our meeting with the
point of view oh uh Mr genus uh you have
the floor and a point of order uh thank
you thank you Mr chair I wonder if you
can clarify the committee passed a
motion specifically wanting to hear from
the UCC and uh we are hearing from them
but for a an unprecedentedly short
period of time and you've heard from
conservatives NDP and block that that we
think the time is uh is too short uh UCC
is an extremely important organization
representing ukrainians across the
country uh in in a of course a very very
challenging context with the war going
on could you clarify for the committee
given the motion that was passed who
made the decision that we should only
hear from them for half an hour today
and uh and was there any rationale given
as to as to why such a short amount of
time for the Ukrainian Canadian Congress
given given their importance and given
the explicit wish of the committee
uh thank you Mr Jones well of course
um I um I'm not sure it's a it's a point
of order
um it's more of a matter of discussion
and negotiations that should be taking
place with the committee having said
that as you're aware I am the vice chair
and subbed in at the last minute and I'm
not
um I was not privy to discussions that
went on with respect to the timing of
the visit by the UCC
I do share some concerns however that at
the time simply not enough and it would
have been nice if it would be nice if
the committee could just simply agree
before the end of this meeting
it was clear to me by the motion that we
were supposed to have more than one
meeting I think it's right in the motion
to hear from Witnesses uh I think we
should all just be able to agree on that
so that we can move forward
um uh so uh I'd leave that uh for a
discussion of committee members that
would be my my recommendation
Mr chair just to clarify you as Vice
chair were not consulted by the point of
order Mr chair that you have clearly
stated that what Mr genuis is doing
right now is does not fall into the
point of order category I would invite
you as chair to please continue on with
the meeting
uh the meeting I I don't think it's a
point of order
um although I think it would be
reasonable to have uh more meetings and
that was what was discussed in the
motion so uh we are at the end of our
meeting uh the first meeting uh we're
going to adjourn I understand new login
details will be issued by the clerk and
we will reconvene at 3 30 central
eastern time that's when they